last night gave me more hope for
president trump's re-election chances
than anything
that has happened in recent weeks what
happened well
i will let kamala harris give it to you
in her own words
it was a debate
not everybody landed punches like you
did though
it was a debate so you don't mean it
it was a debate that the whole reason
literally it was a debate it was called
a debate
i understand traveled to the debate
there were journalists there covering
the debate
where there would be a debate it was
a debate and it showed that when there
is a
fair debate then we crush them
now unfortunately kamala harris has not
learned anything
since her disastrous stephen colbert
interview she got absolutely
wrecked at that debate i hope that the
gop
learns a whole lot from last night i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment uh from yesterday's from
noor russian nor russianese something
like that
on youtube uh referring to
that young man who was a ten-year-old
boy on his
e-school he was asked by his teacher
who is a role model that he looks up to
he said donald trump and got kicked out
of the classroom
uh nor russianese says bet if the kids
said shay guevara he would have gotten
an
a ridiculous that's true that is a
hundred percent true
if the kid showed up to school if you're
allowed to show up to school anymore
if a kid showed up to school wearing a
make america great again shirt that
would be much
much much more controversial than
wearing the shirt
of a communist murderer che guevara
that's the country we live in
how's that for a radical establishment
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door from anywhere with video
doorbells
you can keep an eye on every corner of
your house with easy to install
indoor and outdoor cameras you can
protect your whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system
you can easily install yourself you know
you know i give ring away to my friends
as housewarming gifts well
a couple friends of mine gave me a ring
update the other day they just had a
very
cute little baby and they found out
because of their ring
that they have a coyote that is coming
out into their yard now they would
typically they'd lay out with the
little baby they'd put them on you know
the the lawn
now thanks to ring they know that there
is an animal in there that
probably would not be very safe for that
baby and so they are adjusting their
lives accordingly so just a great
product
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ring.com knowles
comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro the
absolute perfect way to start your ring
experience plus free two-day shipping go
to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
after the presidential debate last week
which was mostly a shouting match and
and
it could have gone better let's put it
that way last night we saw
a really well manicured much more
old-style political debate you had two
politicians on stage
rather than a professional politician
and donald trump
where anything can happen uh you had two
politicians on stage
and in that battle mike pence just
mopped the floor with kamala harris the
best moment of the debate
was when pence landed the punch
that president trump tried to land on
biden that chris wallace was running
interference for
for biden so he wouldn't force him to
answer it was the question of whether or
not
the biden harris administration would
pack the courts
when you speak about the supreme court
though i think the american people
really deserve an answer senator harris
are you and joe biden going to pack the
court if judge amy coney barrett is
confirmed
i mean there have been 29 vacancies on
the supreme court during presidential
election years from george washington to
barack obama
presidents have nominated in all 29
cases
but your party is actually openly
advocating
adding seats to the supreme court which
has had nine seats for 150 years
if you don't get your way this is a
classic case of if you can't win by the
rules
you're going to change the rules now
you've refused to answer the question
joe biden has refused to answer the
question so i think the american people
would really like to know
if judge amy coney barrett is confirmed
at the supreme court of the united
states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
pack the supreme court to get your way
i'm so glad we went through a little
history lesson let's do that a little
more
in 1816 i'd like you to answer the
question mr vice president speaking
i'm speaking i i'm speaking this was her
only defense the whole debate i mean
she went in unprepared she went in with
indefensible positions and she went in
against a seasoned pro now there are
pros and cons to being a really good
politician the thing about donald trump
is by the old model he's not really a
great politician because he actually
does answer questions and he actually
does do things that are pretty
wacky and he's not all that manicured
there's a room for that too because i
think people get tired of the
more stale political format however
when you got politician versus
politician you got to go in
recognizing how to play this and she
absolutely did not so the only thing she
had recourse to
was she would say i'm speaking and she
would kind of get more and more angry
about this all night i'm speaking and
you say
yeah well but answer the question you
know it's fine if you're speaking you
can read a litany of of
whatever you like but but i asked you a
specific question
she couldn't answer it why because she
knows if she says she won't pack the
court she's going to lose her base
she knows if she says she will pack the
court she's going to seem like a radical
there's nowhere for her to go and and
very likely they would pack the corp
so he hits her on the court packing i
was the best one of the night the second
best one
was on energy biden and harris have been
very clear
they would ban fracking but now because
that's pretty radical because that would
really raise energy prices because that
would take away a lot of jobs
now they're trying to pretend that they
don't want to ban fracking and they tell
you with a straight face
they're not going to ban fracking they
tell you with a straight face they're
not going to try to get rid of fossil
fuels
mike pence knows how to twist the knife
we literally have spared no expense to
help the american people in the american
worker through this
joe biden and kamala harris want to
raise taxes
they want to bury our economy under a
two trillion dollar green new deal
which you were one of the original
co-sponsors of in the united states
senate
they want to abolish fossil fuels and
ban
fracking which would cost hundreds of
thousands of american jobs all across
the heartland
joe biden will not end fracking he has
been very clear about that
senator harris you're you're entitled to
your own opinion but you're not entitled
to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the
eye and pointed and said i guarantee
i guarantee that we will abolish fossil
fuels
i will repeat and the american people
know
that joe biden will not ban fracking
that is a
fact that is a fact
that is a fact that is a fact the
problem is that kamala harris said
multiple times during these debates
explicitly
that she's going to ban fracking there's
no question i'm in favor of banning
fracking
so yeah and and starting
and starting with what we can do on day
one around public lands right
whoops whoopsie daisy and you've you've
heard we've played on this show
so many times joe biden saying that he
would
ban fracking no more fracking try to get
rid of fossil fuels so
she had no recourse she couldn't say
listen on
on august 5th i said definitively i
wouldn't ban fracking she can't do it i
mean also as mike pence says she was one
of the
senate co-sponsors of the green new deal
so
what she chose to do was
try to seem very smug very condescending
kind of have this silly smirk on her
face all night
shake her head say no say when mike
pence uses
a cliche you're entitled to your own
opinion but not your own facts she goes
good lyme there were other people saying
that on twitter
and mike pence delivered it well but
that is an old line that's they were
saying that as though they'd never heard
anybody utter it that's a classic old
politician line
i think it was very effective but that's
all she could get in that snide comment
yeah good line yeah
no and mike pence on the other hand
just seemed so sincere he just seemed so
earnest all the time i've never seen
anybody seem more earnest
so you had you had this kind of
performative smugness
versus this performative earnestness and
i gotta tell you the latter played a lot
better at least from my vantage point
then they moved on to foreign policy
foreign policy another area where
where pence was just ready to land
haymakers he comes in
and he brings up the big issue which is
china he brings up the big issue which
is the people who
destroy the global economy because of
the virus the people who
have eaten america's lunch on trade and
manufacturing for 20 years
and crucially the people who president
president then vice president joe biden
cheered on
as we gave them every advantage in the
international
trading scene how would you describe
our fundamental relationship with china
are we competitors
adversaries enemies you'll have two
minutes uninterrupted
susan the trump administration's
perspective and approach to china has
resulted in the loss of american
lives american jobs
and america's standing
there's a weird obsession that president
trump has had
with getting rid of whatever
accomplishment
was achieved by president obama and vice
president biden
what come again what accomplishment
she's asked an explicit question about
china
here i'll tell you what let's let's
roleplay i'm kamala harris
if let's say i'm i'm running for vice
president you ask me is china our enemy
yes
no i didn't get to the other answers you
don't have to yes china's our enemy
china is our number one geopolitical
adversary
it's not even close but kamala harris
can't say that
because joe biden for decades said that
a rising
china is good for everybody in
explicitly
those terms and not so long ago he said
it is a good thing
it's good that china is in the world
trade organization it's good
that china is being allowed to grow
their economy even at the expense
of the american economy even as they
steal property from us even as they take
jobs from us
and so she's got no answer to it so then
she has recourse to what
i think was a not very thinly veiled
racism accusation she goes you know i
don't know what it is about trump
he's got this weird obsession with
repealing
everything obama did so what do you mean
it's a weird obsession
obama is a radical left democrat trump
is a conservative republican
of course he wants to repeal all of his
radical legislation
and radical executive orders the only
reason it would be weird
is the usual accusation that comes up
all the time
that that kamala harris made recourse to
last night which is race she played the
race card whenever she didn't have an
answer she goes you know and i
my mother came here as an immigrant and
i
i'm very proud to be the first black
woman to be the vice presidential
nominee
nobody cares about that nobody cares
about that
we have had a black president it
we have had a female presidential
nominee
from a major party we don't you
it doesn't matter now right you say and
i could be
the if if joe biden is elected and then
you know he doesn't make it through his
term i could be the second black
president who cares everyone cares about
the first one nobody cares about
the second one it's just so silly and it
was a way to evade
the questions and it was a way to evade
mike pence's
attack he finally and
by the way the first right out the gate
the first question was a loaded question
trying to go after
the trump administration on the
coronavirus this
this moderator who was much better than
chris wallace but again damning with
faint praise
this moderator was clearly on the side
of biden and harris
the difference was mike pence just
didn't care
difference was mike pence took the
questions he was asked and
gave the answer that he wanted to give
he took control
of the situation when he was in a
situation that was not advantageous to
him like when i go into a brick and
mortar
auto parts store and i don't know
anything about the parts i take it i
take that situation i make it
advantageous to me by going to
rockauto.com which is a family business
serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
and best of all prices at rockauto.com
are always reliably low they are the
same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers why spend up to twice
as much for the same parts
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices that you
prefer amazing selection reliably low
prices
all the parts that your car will ever
need and best of all
i tell you this website is so simple to
navigate that even i
who doesn't know anything about card
parts even i
can navigate it yeah really terrific i
also i just trust them they've been
around for a long time
family run go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s in
their how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you
right out the gates this was actually
the first question in the debate they
bring up
kovid and kamala accuses
trump and pence of killing all these
sorts of people all this terrible stuff
and then mike pence points out a
question that the mainstream media would
never
ask biden and harris which is what's
your plan
and he goes a little further he points
out that biden plan
that sure looks a whole lot like that
trump plan
we were able to reinvent testing more
than 115 million tests had been done to
date
we were able to see to the delivery of
billions of supplies so our doctors and
nurses had the resources support they
needed
and we began really before the month of
february was art to develop
a vaccine and to develop medicines and
therapeutics had been saving lives all
along the way
and under president trump's leadership
operation warp speed we believe we'll
have
literally tens of millions of doses of a
vaccine before the end of this year
the reality is when you look at the
biden plan it reads an awful lot
like what president trump and i and our
task force have been doing every step
of the way and quite frankly
when i look at their plan that talks
about advancing testing
creating new ppe developing a vaccine
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
oh man iron mike
just absolutely wrecking
biden right there at the end joe biden
of course
very famously infamously had to drop out
of the 1988
presidential race because he was
plagiarizing his speeches
so he gets that n comma here she doesn't
even know what to say
then mike takes it further the vice
president
says okay all right we've got all this
we all agree that our plan is great
thanks biden and harris i'm glad you
agree so now we're about to get this
vaccine so uh senator harris
you're gonna take it you're gonna you're
so you're so interested in public health
you're gonna take that vaccine right
right if the trump administration
approves a vaccine
before or after the election should
americans
take it and would you take it if the
public health professionals if dr fauci
if
the doctors tell us that we should take
it i'll be the first in line to take it
absolutely but if donald trump tells us
i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
oh it's so awkward so
pence is kind of teeing this up and then
you get the question from the moderator
which is
okay well so are you gonna take it and
she can't say yes
now we are told oh my gosh we are told
that we republicans are undermining
public health and
because we won't wear these masks you
know these dirty masks that
many epidemiologists have said we read
one just the other day from colombia
have said people are not using correctly
right the guy from colombia who was
speaking to npr
said that the masks fail in studies
because people just aren't
wearing them right so that i guess she's
going to do that obviously they're not
wearing masks during the debate
but then when the vaccine comes out
listen to the expert's public health
she won't commit to taking it and mike
pence sees his opening and takes it
the reality is that we're going to have
a vaccine
senator in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
we have five companies in phase three
clinical trials
and we're right now producing tens of
millions of doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i just ask
you
stop playing politics with people's
lives the reality is
that we will have a vaccine we believe
before the end of this year
and it will have the capacity to save
countless american lives and and
your continuous undermining of
confidence in a vaccine is just
it's just unacceptable mike pence the
silent
killer you just don't know when he's
going to sneak up on you
the rest of the debate went like that
you you get the picture in many ways
watching this debate was like getting
into a time machine
because this is how all debates used to
be and there was something kind of nice
about it
there was something kind of nice about
this more orderly format
and two politicians you know speaking in
this
very manicured formal way so that
they could get their hits in and you
were just much more familiar with it
president trump blows that up because
president trump doesn't talk in that way
he hasn't been trained in that way
he doesn't know exactly how the hits
work and there's something very
refreshing about that
as well the the contrast of these two
debates
is i think an important one because
i don't know exactly what kind of
country i want i
think a lot of conservatives are feeling
that way i mean i know what policy goals
i want i know what
kind of underlying premises i want but i
don't know what kind of political
culture i want do i want a political
culture
that is like the old model where you
didn't you couldn't quite tell what the
politicians were saying because
you knew they were all just jockeying
for position or do i want a political
model where people
actually just come right out and say
what they mean and it's not always
pretty
but hey we don't have time for that we
got big problems
which one do we want i don't think it's
very
even the most raw raw conservatives or
even the most
establishment squishes i'm not sure that
it's very clear right now which they
want
it's why though i do know this there's
one conclusion i can draw
the combination of trump and pence
is absolutely killer it's just
magnificent there was a lot of talk
early on they said well you've got to
dump
pence from the ticket pence doesn't add
anything
pence adds a lot that guy is a
varsity level total pro
politician who knows how to work it who
is smooth
who has been in dc obviously for
considerably longer than donald trump
and then trump adds that populist
pizzazz
who's actually punching through the
established norms that combination
i don't know that we've ever seen
anything like it in american politics
it was tremendous you don't get to see
the pence side of it so much because
he's silent he kind of works a little
bit more in the background but you got a
glimpse of it last night that's very
powerful
much much better than the the
biden-harris ticket i'm obviously i'm
not even just talking about policy as a
matter of policy i much prefer the trump
ticket but even just as a matter of
political skill harris does not
add very much to joe biden it was a
mistake to pick her
he backed himself into a corner because
he chose to
to be a racist and a sexist i guess to
use their language right he said
my vp it's not going to be necessarily
the best person for the job
it has to be a woman and it has to be a
woman of color
and i don't want it to be elizabeth
warren so i'm going to take native
americans out of it and it's got to be
this and it's got to be that and he just
chose these kind of all these divisive
categories before he got to the person
and then the two choices that were left
on the at a prominent level were
karen caron bass who's a a
communist and who she's the head of the
congressional black caucus
and kamala harris who is just not a
skilled politician
at that level at that level she's she's
very weak he should have
biden should have gone with bootage or
warren or klobuchar or something like
that
uh he didn't do it and it's it's
probably probably going to hurt him by
the end of the debate
the spin doctors the only thing that
they could work with
the only thing left to attack them to
attack the republicans for
was that mike pence's wife was not
wearing a mask it was
absolutely a preposterous line of attack
but that's what they do you know they
try to just hone in and see what your
vulnerability is in this case
there wasn't much vulnerability so they
had to just go for this very weak thing
but a lot of people are looking for your
vulnerabilities when you're on the
internet
do you know what big tech and big
government have in common they both
want to silence any dissenting voices
into
submission okay so that what they're
going to do is they're going to look
through all your data
and then the minute that you say
something that's slightly out of line
and
you're looking at things they're
slightly out of line they're going to
flag you
and they're going to censor you and
they're going to try to get you
off of these platforms to fight back
against having your voice
censored i strongly recommend expressvpn
expressvpn encrypts 100
of internet data for protection against
hackers and against eavesdroppers and
against
those sensors expressvpn is by far the
best vpn out there it is the vpn rated
number one by cnet wired and countless
other tech
publications very important i know that
you think
no one's coming after your data and
nobody's looking into your stuff they
are people we don't think about this all
the time just turn it on
let it be there and then you can be
protected and have peace of mind stop
letting big tech and big government
censor and track you
defend your rights protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
michael that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael get three months free visit
expressvpn.com
michael to learn more the biggest
attack line on the left from the debate
at the end of the debate
you have kamala and biden are up there
or kamala rather and mike pence are up
there they obviously are not wearing
masks the moderator is up there she's
not wearing a mask
you have kamala's husband walks up to
hug her
wearing a mask so
lame so obviously expected and then
karen pence who's a normal person gets
up there and kisses her husband without
having this
piece of cloth in between in between her
and her husband
the left was furious also his wife did
not wear a mask when she was on stage at
the end
everybody other than the candidates and
the moderator were supposed to be
wearing a mask karen pence was not
wearing a mask at the end
it's bizarre you know what you could
save lives if you would do that and you
might in fact be saving somebody's life
in the room right now if in fact your
husband was exposed
to a coveted infected person in the past
week which he was yeah
so let me just ask a question of my
doppelganger over here from msnbc rachel
maddow
she's saying that if if karen pence
had worn a mask when she
walked directly to her husband and
kissed him
she could have saved lives because then
she
she wouldn't have exposed herself to
someone who's been exposed to someone
who had coronavirus and even though mike
pence has tested negative ever since
she was exposed to so he was exposed to
someone with chronic virus that would
have saved lives
does rachel maddow know that mike and
parent cancer pens are married
does she know that they're going to see
each other they're probably going to
drive home together
they're probably going to walk into
their house together
i suspect they're going to get into bed
together and they're not going to be
wearing masks over their mouths while
they sleep
what in what bizarro universe
does a wife kissing her husband spread
coronavirus
but coronavirus is not going to be
spread by mike pence the guy who was
in contact with president trump it's not
going to be spread by him not wearing a
mask it's just karen pence
and the moderator it's fine if she
doesn't kamala harris it's fine if she
doesn't
it was so weak i don't think even rachel
maddow believed that line of attack they
just
had nothing else they had one more i'm
sorry that's not true they had one
more line of attack which was i guess
the dnc sent out the talking points
right after the debate they probably
wrote them before the debate
to abc to cnn to msnbc
the attack on on mike pence because he
won every point on the
merits but he was mansplaining
obviously mike pence his former
television commentator does have a very
calm demeanor
but i think a lot of people were
noticing some mansplaining going on
tonight
i don't know i didn't see it that way
george it didn't come across to me
this was it was a man mansplainer in
chief i guess
mike mansplainer i understand that one
thing stood out to me is i will not be
elected dr harris said that multiple
times
women hate to be elected by men and she
drove that plane home
it was a debate to use camallero's own
words
it's a debate that's where you that's
where you lecture each other that's
where you make points and and you try to
explain things
total weak sauce i don't think even
these guys believe it
you know van jones especially not van
jones that guy's actually intelligent i
think but
but he has to use this line i guess the
talking points came down he's a
mansplainer
they wrote this one obviously before the
debate as a last-ditch effort
because by definition anything mike
pence said in the debate is mansplaining
because he's a man
right she's a woman and that was the the
only card that they had to play
uh mansplaining is very good a girl
understanding is very good too
as my friend andrew clavin says
there's there's nothing wrong with
mansplaining men are perfectly uh
perfectly entitled to
speak i'm sorry if that offends kamala
harris
and i'm sorry if kamala harris is not
quite as skilled at speaking or not as
in command of the facts
or not as able to defend her utterly
indefensible positions because the left
is indefensible they've got no good
arguments to get people to vote for them
in
2020 so now they've they've
truly devolved decayed become debased
the usual insufferable celebrity psa has
now become even yuckier because you have
all of these
some frequently washed up celebrities
left-wingers going out and saying you
gotta vote you gotta vote you gotta vote
but this time you wanna hear the hook
this time they're all naked
i'm completely back ass naked i'm naked
i'm like naked there isn't a man behind
me these are my hands
why you want me to be naked i know what
you're thinking you're thinking ruffalo
um put your clothes on to be honest i
wish i could
cover my hands with my boobs but here we
are i'm here to talk to you about voting
did you know
that ballads could be naked and if you
don't do exactly what i tell you your
ballot could get thrown out
this is uh my ballot just got it first
of all when your ballot comes you're
supposed to read the instructions
read and follow the instructions that
come
with your ballot if they say to use the
black pen use a black pen
i know that's like literally the least
sexy thing a completely naked person
could say but
[Music]
but i have cram like can of pepsi his
problem
uh our founding fathers roll over in
their graves
because the left is kind of hilariously
depicting what they warned us all
against
you know the the founding fathers had
deliberative
discussion they had substantive debate
the federalist papers were op-eds
that were written to debate the
constitution but they all said they said
you know if
if license takes over licentiousness if
people just give over to their base
passions we're not going to be able to
have self-government you need to be in
control of your passions to have
self-government and so what do these
people do they say we're all naked
we're all naked come vote for us credit
where credit's due
sarah silverman looks a lot better than
i think any of us expected okay i'm
willing i want i don't want to be
totally one-sided here we were a lot of
people were surprised by that
however however uh the psa was
completely
unconvincing and really off-putting and
really really gross
not even gross because those people
generally don't look very good
but gross because you think gosh this is
how debased our politics
has become a quick update on the trump
covid stimulus plan i told you this
yesterday i predicted it i believe i was
the only person yesterday to
to call this when everybody was freaking
out they were all so upset
that president trump said that he was
not going to negotiate a covid relief
deal
until after the election he said sorry
nancy you're offering me 2.4 trillion
i'm saying
1.6 trillion no deal we're just going to
focus on barrett we'll do it after the
election
all these conservatives said no what are
you doing you're losing you're crazy
don't do it
and i said yesterday i said guys i'm not
even going to take him at face value
here
because i think this is just a
negotiating tactic well
not 24 hours later turns out that seems
to be the case
trump tweets out yesterday if i am sent
a standalone bill for stimulus checks
1200 bucks they will go out to our great
people immediately i'm ready to sign now
are you listening nancy
move fast i'm waiting to sign at speaker
pelosi so
this was uh this was a negotiating
tactic we'll see if it happens
either way i think it kind of works for
him trump's put himself in a bit of a
win-win
situation but uh
very very good news art of the deal
shows you most people
still not catching it even you know
president trump has let us in now i mean
if you're if you're paying close
attention to trump you realize
this is the kind of thing he does but a
lot of people still i think
they're they're just not used to it and
it's why by the way that
trump strategy is usually more effective
than the pen strategy even if the pen
strategy is much cleaner and when you
put them both together you get a really
dynamite ticket
this is an art politics is not just
merely a science
people you always hear about political
science and universities and things like
that but politics
is is a little bit more an art and you
know that i love art i especially love
the portrait that i just got from
paintyourlife.com i just got it
yesterday
paintyourlife.com i've told you about
them now for years at this point
you get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo
at a very very affordable price and it's
hand painted i have mine done in oil
they have other options as well so i
tried this out
sweet little lisa and i decided to have
a portrait done of my mother from an old
photograph that we had
we send it in i i can't get over it i
cannot get over how
incredible this portrait is you can see
it i posted
a photo of it on my instagram so you can
go to instagram.com slash michael j
knowles you can see this
this photo of this portrait it just
unbelievable unbelie truly world-class
artists
uh you work with them until every detail
is perfect so you're giving them notes
the whole time
it's custom-made and you you can order
this custom-made portrait in less than
five minutes
it's a perfect gift for the holidays as
they come up
and it's perfect just for you for your
own home to to add beauty to your home
and add something that's really special
and that's that is unique at
paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded
guaranteed right now is a limited time
offer you get 20 off your painting
20 off an already low price free
shipping to get the special offer right
now text michael to 64 000
mich ael to 64 000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter
most you are going to be blown away by
these guys
i've got to get to a hilarious
post from media matters yesterday and
i've got to get to the mail bag but
first if you liked our debate coverage
last night you should join
daily wire right now as an insider or
all access member get 20
off with code debate so that you can
watch all of our upcoming debate
coverage live on dailywire.com apple tv
the roku app
you get so much exclusive daily wire
content of course and then
not one but two leftist tears tumblers
one for you and one for your honey get
20
off right now off your daily wire
membership with code debate
when you sign up today we will be right
back with a lot more
i got to get to the mailbag i know i'm
running late but i have to point this
out a guy from media matters yesterday
posts this long long thread about
how after rbg died he listened to aoc
and he knew there's someone in your life
who you've got to get
to vote in this election it's your job
to do it and he's been filled with
anxiety and
for him it's his 94 year old grandmother
it goes on and on and on and on and it
just
it never ends this whole long thread but
then
finally at the end he says i told her to
vote for republi that a vote for
republicans was a vote
that would harm me and my future i told
her i was scared
and today my grandmother promised me she
would vote for joe biden she told me i'm
the love of her life she wouldn't break
your
promise i'm still crying i had never
called her crying but i did today i'm
still crying please call your loved ones
remember
the long and short of it is a grown man
who works for media matters
called his grandmother and cried until
she agreed to vote for biden
which is why you know i joke about media
matters a lot i joke about
our official daily wire intern jason
campbell who works for
media matters who does all my publicity
he breaks out my clips and things like
that
but i i try not to be very mean to them
i try not to be cruel
some some people who immediate matters
exists to get
me and other people fired and but i try
not to be cruel to them because these
are extremely broken people
obviously i mean this guy he's like
crying to his 94 year old grandmother
i mean these people some of them have
put videos on the internet like
talking about how not broken they are
but they're obviously like
it this is these are people who have
troubles okay
and it just makes me think of a view of
politics where
you can go you can totally knock these
guys you can have
fun you can hit him and just
kill him with kindness that that is kind
of my view of it
that's what mike pence did last night at
the debate he killed him with kindness
okay he killed them in a in a way that
was very civilized and i think a lot of
us liked it and i i
i would like to to institute more of
that in my personal behavior
and i i i would like to see more of that
in the country
unfortunately if the left doesn't relent
then we're going to need more
more trumps we're going to need more
trump strategies which is a little
a little less soft a little a little
less a little less gentle
some of the some of the older strategies
also have to point out
before we get to the mailbag someone
just died last week
that would be the grandson of president
john tyler john tyler was the 10th
president of the united states
he was president from 1841 to 1845
and his grandson just died last week
his grandson lion gardner-tyler jr
died september 26th 175 years after his
grandfather left office he was the son
of lion
gardener tyler senior who was born in
1853
when his father who was born in 1790 was
62.
obviously john tyler and john tyler's
son both had kids when they were very
late in life
i mentioned that to remind you this is a
young country
the country was founded officially in
1776. so when we talk about
unprecedented breaking all the norms
this is a very young country we still
don't know how it's going to settle we
haven't been around
for a long time it's still a fragile
institution difficult
to preserve and those are going to be
stakes in this election let's get to the
mailbag from dan
do you think at this point joe biden is
the presidential equivalent of the
affordable care act
just like we were told we had to pass
the act to find out what was in it
the same is now true with joe biden yes
joe biden is speaking out of both sides
of his mouth it's very clear he says i
would never ban fracking i absolutely
will ban fracking
i'm not going to go after charter
schools i absolutely will go after
charter schools so you just
you don't know what you're going to get
with him because i don't think he knows
what he's going to get with him he
unlike the affordable care act which
actually no no actually i'll correct
myself the affordable care act is a good
analogy
because the affordable care act even
though it was seven zillion pages long
didn't include most of the specifics
about the law because what the
affordable care act did was just
empower the deep state it empowered the
administrative agencies
the bureaucracy to write most of these
regulations
well same thing with joe biden that's
what he's going to do he's going to if
he gets into office god forbid
he gets in he's just going to empower
the bureaucrats to make all of the
decisions
which is a very bad thing and it's a bad
thing not just because of the
uncertainty but
really because of the certainty because
we know that that is going to take the
country in a much more
leftward direction from elizabeth do you
think pope francis will praise the peace
deals
made in the middle east between israel
and those various countries
you know the holy father doesn't consult
me on these things
so i don't i don't know i couldn't
couldn't make a prediction
obviously a lot of conservatives are not
too happy with the pope
because he has said many left-wing
things he has appeared to be very
critical of the president sometimes he's
been taken out of context by
journalists but then that raises the
question why is he still talking do
these journalists always take him out of
context
the the issue here that i would always
recommend to conservatives even when
we're talking about pope francis
is a little bit of caution because
the catholic church and european history
generally european history which is
shaped by
the catholic church is not quite as
simple
as our understanding of conservatism and
liberalism and left and right today in
america
we have a much narrower understanding of
those things but when you
when you open it up over time and you
look at
historical context things get a little
bit broader and more complicated
i mean just even in america probably
this is changing now but it was true
maybe for the past 10 years
you would say someone who is very very
libertarian is very very conservative
but for most of the history of our
civilization
someone who is very very libertarian
would be considered very very liberal or
very much on the left even our
understanding of left and right are
products of the french revolution which
is very very modern
so it just urge a bit of caution uh
conservative thought uh western
civilization western culture
is much broader than the ideological
categories that that we are talking
about
today from aidan i've been pondering
this question for a while i was
wanting your take on this a lot of
conservatives state that the majority of
the country supports trump but what
exactly is the proof
how can one prove that the majority of
the country is in fact for trump
a simple conversation with a leftist
they of course say no they point to the
polls how trump lost the popular vote in
2016 even though i think
that those votes were faked well some of
them might have been you know but
i don't know if all two million or
however many were faked thank you for
your time and all that you do it depends
what you mean
by the country the majority of the
country
does support donald trump in the sense
that we are the united states of america
we are not the individuated people of
america
without any distinction by geography or
by state we are not
the simple national government of
america without any subsidiary or
federalism
or the united states of america the way
the presidential vote is
tallied is through the electoral college
which has a relation to the popular vote
but it is not identical with the popular
vote so the majority of the country
such as it is elects trump and supports
trump
the majority of the individuals did not
vote for trump
but the country is more than just the
individuals and this is a point
that conservatives have been a little
bit weak on for the past 20 years
because of the influence of
libertarianism
we have thought that because the left is
for big government and collectivism and
socialism we have thought that the best
way to fight that
is to be for individualism
there's a role obviously for the
individual in an opposition to the left
but that's not the whole story actually
if you
say that the individual is the basic
unit of society rather than say
the family or the local community you're
giving the left
their premise because the left says the
same thing that the individual is the
basic unit of society
socialists say the same thing communists
say the same thing fascists actually say
the same thing
now those are all different political
ideologies right but they all share that
basic premise
that destroys the mediating institutions
that destroys the individual states and
the local communities and especially the
family
and the churches and the civic
associations and it has the individual
and then libertarians say we want the
individuals to stand on their own
and the left-wingers say and the
fascists for that matter say
we want the individuals to be bound up
together fascism means like a bundle a
bundle of sticks
we want them all to be bound up together
in the state
and both of those guys get it wrong
because the correct answer is
the individual is not the atomic unit of
society
the family is within the context of
mediating institutions and
local government and civic associations
and churches
that's the basic unit and it's much much
tougher
for political demagogues to come in and
take power from
from that from that structure of
subsidiary and federalism
much tougher it's much this is why
as as libertarianism has advanced
leftism has advanced too
because they're not opposites they're
actually two sides of the same coin so
i think we've got to stop thinking about
the the
essential unit of the country as
individuals
of course individuals have unique
dignity
uh they have so much to add and we need
to support
individualism in as much as it speaks to
human dignity but as a political
unit we have to pay much much much more
attention to the state government
to the local government and especially
to the family
from chris on your show the other day
you talked about
your support for capital punishment i
did as a fellow catholic i'm conflicted
on my support for the death penalty
due to the church's opposition to it
not so fast there but let's get the rest
of your question then i'll answer how do
you justify
your support of the death penalty along
with your faith i'm not asking as a
gotcha i'm genuinely interested in your
thought process
since this is something i've always been
confused about yeah i think
in recent years the church has been very
confusing sent out messages
that are that are difficult to parse and
in some cases perhaps
even contrary to the history of
of the church in church's traditional
teaching
the death penalty is perfectly
legitimate as pope benedict xvi said
just a few years ago
there can be legitimate disagreement
among catholics
faithful catholics on the death penalty
pope john paul ii said the same thing
though he was very anti-death penalty
some of his predecessors were not so
anti-death penalty
blessed pope pius ix not only supported
the death penalty
he carried out many capital punishments
in the papal states so was blessed pius
ix
who is on his way to canonization did he
commit this intrinsically evil act
and permit it no i don't think so thomas
aquinas
defends the death penalty capital
punishment was thomas aquinas doctor of
our church
one of the greatest theologians ever to
live was he
advocating intrinsic evil no
saint paul who says that this the civil
authority wields the sword
for a reason does not wield it in vain
was he teaching intrinsic evil in
in the new testament uh i don't think so
i don't think so there
you'll notice by the way even the recent
statements of the
present father holy father do not use
the phrase intrinsic evil
they say that it's inadmissible or sort
of you know it's a little
confusing but won't use the phrase
intrinsic evil because that would be
indefensible that would be contrary to
scripture
and contrary to 2 000 years of church
teaching
so no the church may have as the
catechism states
and has stated now for a couple decades
at least a prudential
opposition a a as a practical matter
they don't like it
and discourage it but it is not against
the moral teaching of the catholic
church
to say that the death the death penalty
can be legitimate and so
i have no problem reconciling my faith
and my political views on that
because they're very much in line from
jesse one last question before we go
i've noticed that you haven't given us a
new pithy name for the novel coronavirus
in recent weeks
so i thought i would give you a
suggestion for one i think we should
call the disease
the xi jin plague in honor of the man
slash willy-nilly silly old bear
whose fault this pandemic truly is it's
a great name
the xi jin plague i on that note i can't
do better than that
on that note i'm michael knowles this is
michael knowles i'll see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton